en toda Florida los trabajadores
indocumentados Están preocupados por su
futuro el gobernador ron de santis firmó
lo que llamó el proyecto de ley contra
la inmigración ilegal más fuerte de la
nación para prohibir que los que no
tienen papeles acepten trabajos en el
estado a partir del primero de julio las
empresas con 25 o más empleados tendrán
que comprobar la situación legal de
todos los nuevos empleados mediante el
sistema federal y verify bajo amenazas
de fuertes multas Aunque la ley aún no
ha entrado en vigor ya está teniendo
repercusiones
ya se ha ido de este edificio
de todas las obras están guiando todos
según el centro de estudios migration
institute de los 22 millones de
residentes de Florida
772 mil son indocumentados y si se les
eliminara de las nóminas la economía del
Estado podría sufrir una pérdida de casi
13.000 millones de dólares el estado
depende en gran medida de la mano de
obra inmigrante digan lo que digan
está probando activamente legislación
perjudicial que no resuelve nada que
daña nuestra economía que crea miedo e
incertidumbre en quienes solo quieren
que les dejen en paz pagar sus impuestos
y mantener a sus familias
algunos inmigrantes dicen que si no
pueden trabajar Se mudarán y encontrarán
trabajo en otro estado lo que supondrá
un golpe devastador para las empresas de
Florida